All right,
everybody.
It's tipsy elves.
That's right.
Tipsy elves.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater this time of year.
If you want bragging rights for the most.
Talked about sweater,
your Christmas party.
Listen Up.
Did you see these guys on shark tank a couple of weeks ago with their latest
update?
Everyone is talking about tipsy elves,
not in my world
and wants their outrageous Christmas sweaters I share.
They are and the Christmas sweater circles.
I'm sure this,
this conversation is all a fire.
Anyways,
talk about you're tipsy elves sweater and other products you saw on the website.
Oh,
I didn't see any.
Trust me when I tell you that these tipsy elves Christmas sweaters are like
nothing you've ever seen before.
They are not for the faint of heart.
Nobody's worn these ugly sweaters before,
uh,
before you,
so you don't have to worry about finding your size and you have a ton of styles
to choose from while you're shopping for an ugly sweater.
Checkout the other holiday and collegiate attire for yourself or as a gift like
an adult.
Onesy
do what kind of perverts or running this thing.
This sounds like,
ah,
shut up bill.
Just read it.
I right now my listeners get 20% off tipsy elves.com or anything they order on
their site.
Go do this now so they have the best selection to choose from and have it in
time for your ugly Christmas sweater party.
Go to tipsy elves.com and use the Promo Code Berm.
Who the hell wasn't adult onesie?
That's like those fucking people that still act like babies.
You know what I mean?
They have a giant adult crib.
Remember that on Opie and Anthony was fucking infuriating.
Anyways,
merry Christmas everybody.
Oh,
it's my favorite.
Here we go.
Club Debbie,
everybody club.
Debbie a tear.
My daddy bought me a ranch.
Uh,
don't you hate when wine looks like a 10 but it winds up looking like a tasting,
like a six or even worse when you walk into the store to pick out your wine,
you could easily be fooled into a situation like this.
Well now there's this new wine club club,
Debbie.
We knew about isis before they did.
They've changed everything.
No more being fooled by wines that pretend to be hotter or tastier than they
actually are.
It's easy.
Just go to club Debbie Club,
Debbie W.
Dot Com and answer six simple questions.
Their algorithm creates a palate profile just for you.
Then they send wine directly to your door,
to your door,
perfectly customized to match your taste club.
Debbie full.
We want still very,
and hackathon weekend is leading the grape to glass wine revolution.
They work directly with the vineyards to cut out the middlemen would saved you
money.
So when you go to club,
Debbie,
I'm smarter than Jip.
You get premium wine customized to your tastes at a third of what you would pay
at the store.
They even have a no risk hundred percent guarantee that you're going to love
what they send you.
And right now when you go to club,
Debbie have don't count.
The votes is offering my listeners 50% off your first order.
When you go to club.
Debbie Downer is going to be toast club,
w.
Dot com slash birth.
So stop wasting time and money messing around at retail stores and start
drinking wine.
Uh,
you know,
you're going to love,
just go to club Debbie [inaudible] Komen Club,
w.
Dot com slash bird to get 50% off your first order.
That's club debbie.com/bar.
I'll just do like a quick little intro.
Yeah,
sure man.
All right.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast that just checking in on you.
Just checking in on your week here.
As mentioned,
um,
I was going to have a special guest,
uh,
one of my favorite comedians of all time and I still think brutally,
brutally fucking underrated.
Uh,
Mr Peek,
Cory,
Ellie.
Um,
I've known him since,
so I moved to New York.
He's got a new special,
let me get all this shit out of the way.
He's got a new special or that streaming on showtime kids.
God knows you guys like the streaming stuff.
Alright.
And it's called,
let me tell Ya.
Just came out to rave reviews.
One of my favorite comics and people of all time,
Mr p Corey alley,
Billy Billy.
I don't even,
I don't even know how to take that intro.
Dude.
I want to hug you across the table.
I got to put that in a bind.
I had like a studio audience.
Fucking brutally,
brutally underrated.
It's as if it is.
My wife is saying the words in the kitchen.
What did she say that,
oh dude,
I swear.
I mean come on.
Two weeks before I did the special,
before he came out,
I was on,
I was on a boat.
I was on a cruise.
Who's on a cruise?
Why two weeks before this special comes out?
Why?
Well,
no,
you already know.
You already,
you already taped it.
You weren't already taped.
Yeah.
You got balls,
man.
I'd be free.
I was too.
I thought you were saying two weeks before you tape the fucking thing.
You were on a cruise.
Like I got this.
No,
no,
no.
I'm drinking a bud light.
Can you imagine?
No,
I mean I'm no forming on a cruise.
I mean,
at some point I would do a joke and I literally just say,
and they sit at the bar and put bread on my gr and say,
man,
what are you?
And they don't get it.
They don't even get it right.
Anyway.
I appreciate it.
Yeah,
Dude.
What,
uh,
let me ask you this too.
When you go to do a special,
like when do you feel like your hours ready?
Do you ever,
I don't know man.
I don't know.
It's just crazy.
The fight.
It's the first one I did.
I felt a little more like it was ready.
Like it was,
it was like,
you know,
because I never did the first one just,
you're always ready because you've been doing it for fucking ever wait for
somebody to give you a shot.
And I never did a half hour of any kind.
So it was really,
I had the whole gamut.
Everything I ever written up until that point was what?
A half hour for comedy central?
No,
no,
at the time.
Well the time,
by the time he came point,
my manager goes,
I think we can get you a half hour.
I go,
I think I can,
I got an hour.
Yeah.
So I laid it down at a club and sent it to them and they right away gave me the
hour and I felt really great after that.
And then the second one was a bit more of a grind,
like really grinding it out.
Um,
again,
you're one of the guys,
like,
I watch how you're doing it and like,
you know,
and uh,
and Louie too.
And I'm like,
how,
what did these guys sleeping at night and elves and writing this shit and
putting in about a foot of their bed can't keep up.
So,
but by the end,
you know,
I,
I really felt it was there,
but I gotta tell you,
man,
if I had to wait like six more months to tape that special,
I probably would have forgotten what was funny about some of those jokes.
That's what thinks so.
But I always have to.
You get it right to the point where you're like,
dude,
I'm so fucking sick of doing this.
And then it's like,
okay,
I've got to burn this thing.
Yeah.
And then uh,
move on.
So I tried to do,
I'm like just about every other year or so.
So this year coming up is the year where maybe towards the end of the year I'm
going to do it.
I was just talking to my guy about it and you know he's going to do,
you're ready,
you're ready.
I'm like Nah,
I don't think I,
I gotta make sure there's a few things I want to push a little bit further cause
cause you're competing against your last one.
So it has to be at least that level,
which you never want it to be because then it's more of the same from bill burr.
Right.
Which is,
which is worse than somebody saying you suck.
You know,
and everybody in the Internet's such cons pumped.
He's going to fucking know what I mean,
you're working at a top level.
It's like if you bet in three 40 every years,
three 40 year,
if the year really that bad,
but I got to say the last special,
all you stuff is just unreal.
But when you did the bit where you're playing catch with the dude,
are you kidding me?
I mean that's like I could see a kid watching,
I'm sorry.
That's,
that's like on the level of the greatest of greats.
So it was like,
all right,
I'm sorry I'm sitting there and watching that.
But the difference between where you're at too though is you are the only one
that decides.
Right?
Like for me,
when I,
I knew I wanted to do it with showtime,
I didn't want to go back to these places where the air at once and it's done.
Yeah.
He can't do that now.
Right.
So I got to the point where I sent it to them and they go,
we're not saying no,
but we're not saying yes,
but they were nice enough to work with me.
Right.
So I tweaked some stuff cause I had some stuff that was just current events and
I'm not a current event guy.
So I,
I,
I worked on another six months,
sent it back in and then the guy he's at showtime said,
all right,
come to la,
we want to see it once live and we'll make our dishes and decision basically at
the end of the night.
So I'm like 10 minutes and people that they're just given away half hours to the
fact that you got to jump through all these extra hoops.
They fly you off course now?
No ma'am.
Not that I stayed at the safari in Burbank
and you know,
I got 10 minutes left to the sets.
Go agree.
You know,
I mean it's the Ice House two week pass too,
you know,
but you like 10 minutes left,
you're like,
nobody dropped a glass.
Come on man.
And it went great.
I know what great.
And finally I got it and I really,
you know,
and,
and looking back on it,
I'm like,
man,
I'm glad these guys made me wait six months because it's better than it was six
months ago.
Definitely.
And if I could decide when I can do my own specialist,
my next one will be coming out next Wednesday.
Oh really?
Well not really,
but you,
you know,
you,
you sometimes you think something's great and then like a year lady like I can't
believe.
I thought that was great.
Now it's great.
Right?
See that's,
that's my paranoia is like you want to do in that perfect thing where you're
sick of the fucking thing and you can't squeeze anything.
We can't bring anything up a little bit better.
You taped it right at the perfect time.
But what's fucked up dude is we would just,
when you came in here for the people listening here,
uh,
is,
I don't know,
it's just you get to a certain age and just years,
even though you counting with birthdays,
they,
everything just feels like it was five years ago and you were talking about,
we played this,
this touch football game,
all these comics in a central park and we used,
that was like 20 years ago.
I was like,
oh man.
I thought it was like early two thousands and I was thinking,
I was with Bobby Kelly and we were trying to figure out what we,
so,
so it was,
we were so sore the next day.
I was like,
yeah dude,
come on man with 30.
He goes,
dude,
don't fucking say that.
And I'm not 30 cause he was like,
the efficacy is like two,
three years younger than me,
but I was 29 Gunna to be 30.
So that means that it was sometime in 1997 it's almost 2016.
Yeah,
it was fucking 20 years ago.
And I remember fucking Bobby getting so far,
I've told this story of the old at the show,
Bobby got so fucking mad,
um,
during that game,
uh,
I was blocking them or something and like he just,
I,
I saw it as like his nostrils were flaring.
He got all competitive,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
And he was,
he was going to come in,
I think I had a couple of couches and he didn't have any yet.
He's so funny.
So he gets all competitive so it's fucking nostrils of flared and he comes
flying at me.
Right.
And like he just took the wrong step.
I just sort of pushed him down to the ground and it was just sort of effortless
cause he kind fucked her.
I remember that he started falling first,
so I just sort of guided him to the ground.
It was like when Don Zimmer ran it fucking Pedro,
he just thought it guy,
he got so mad,
he fucking grabbed two handfuls of grass,
ripped them out of the ground and then just both hands fucking throw them at
them at me as hard as he could.
And I was like four feet away from,
so for like two feet,
the grass goes like 90 million miles an hour and then it was grass and they're
like a foot later just when like [inaudible] between the two of us.
And I was looking at him like,
what the fuck?
I remember that one of the,
one of those kids,
you know,
we didn't know everybody was some Puerto Rican kid there and he just looks at
Bobby.
He goes,
Yo,
he buggy and I just started laughing.
It was one of them.
That is one of the maddest I ever saw him.
But uh,
through,
we used to fucking play rollerblade hockey.
This is all 90 shit.
And I remember we used to like every six games,
me and him would almost get into a fist fight.
We never quite got to that level.
But uh,
but through that was way back in the day we used to work,
uh,
the men of the Boston Comedy Club.
Giana man,
when are you kidding me?
Of course.
I mean that was lazy.
I don't think,
I don't,
I always wondered if it was because we were new to doing stand up.
Yeah,
yeah.
That and we didn't know what we were doing that that room was so like,
just like just the death that you could die in,
in that fucking building or if it really was as difficult.
I mean,
it's fucking insane.
When I first came down like 94,
it's like people selling drugs right outside the front of it.
You walked in,
it was an absolute shit hole.
Barry Katz owned it,
put like fucking 3 cents into the thing.
Had that old fucked up.
I'll look at violet places.
Yeah,
of course.
Behind you on stage in like the piece of wood could come out and I just
remembered when you went in there,
it was like a,
I don't know if it was any other room,
I would have been like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
After I took a pound and be like,
fuck this place.
This place is fucked up.
But,
but there was something about it because of the comics that were working their
eyes,
it will work and they were insane.
Yeah.
You wanted to be able to have a good set in there.
You will.
Oh God.
When you first broke in there,
you will like nervous and then,
and then like maybe a year or so when you find yourself putting your elbow on
the mantle,
that's when you know you're comfortable there.
Dude,
I got to,
one of the most embarrassing things in my life on stage happened at that club.
It was so,
it was one of those urban knights.
Okay.
Do one of the 12 embarrassing things in my life happened and I fucking club now.
I was,
I was only about,
I don't know,
maybe a year into comedy.
Right.
And it just started becoming a little friendly with brewer.
So now I go down there one night and I would just hang out and try to get on
that sort of thing.
And brewer in Chappelle meetup and a,
they're going to go around the corner.
This is again,
years and years ago,
and they're going to smoke a joint and they invite me to go,
oh,
this is like 92 three,
four like 94 or five.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we go around the bend.
So just to put it perspective,
men in tights for no nutty professor he was making and brewers on Saturday night
was,
okay,
cool.
All right.
Because we go around the band and I'm like just being quiet.
So excited to be hanging here.
Right.
And was smoking a joint and a Chappelle's tell him the famous story about his
end from Eddie Murphy being mad at David Spade for that.
You remember that famous story where spates look a falling star and it's a
picture of Eddie Murphy catch a falling star yet just recently wrote a blog
about it.
It's like famous,
everybody knows that story's still going on.
I think he finally saw Eddie and Eddie said,
hey,
what's up?
So I think it's finally like fucking 20 years later,
it's finally over.
Yeah.
And in that point it was wild because I'm sitting there getting Chappelle's end
of it,
cause he's doing nutty professor would Eddie Murphy when that happened.
Right.
And then brewers on with spade on Saturday night live.
So they tell on each on this version of the phone call and stuff.
And I'm like,
wow.
So then we go back to the club and again,
packed urban night.
As we said it was a little cold.
So I'd gotten there early and I put my coat down though.
So this is Sunday night.
The all black show,
people don't know what urban night.
Yeah.
And then urban outfitter night.
And this is important to know because I put my coat down and they both high and
Jason,
who runs a club at the time goes,
who wants to go first?
Jim,
you debut?
And they go,
no,
let me relax.
And they go put PD on per PT on,
you know,
I'm freaking high.
I'm not even good at comedy really.
So they put me on first diet,
right?
I'm bombing,
I'm three minutes in brewer and Chappelle,
Dian Laugh.
And uh,
I do about five minutes to deploy.
We didn't know what black people go and he's Connie [inaudible],
Connie,
brutal.
I get off and now all I want to do is go home.
Right?
I can't find my fucking coat.
I have no idea what my code is,
my keys to my apartment or in my coat.
It's totally dark.
I'm doing that.
When you're walking around and you swear it's under somebody's seat and you're
like,
can I just,
can I just be,
I just saw you bomb.
Yeah.
And that he's willing to go,
what you want,
what you want.
And then there's a black and he goes,
what's going on back there that's going on back there?
And somebody yells out,
white boy,
he can't find his coat.
Do I book him?
So he goes fucking lights on and they turned the lights on and they're all
looking around guns,
this joke,
all this shit.
And I'm walking around and trying to find him.
Finally some lady in the back,
I remember I put it by that little bar in the bag there.
She goes,
this gel coat and I go,
yeah.
And I go over,
I get my coat and they go,
you keep warm,
get out of your wife or my,
my on.
I just took my coat and they put the lights out and I went home.
You know something.
I hate to lose like that any more.
They do five minutes of stand up and then they run a God damn special.
Sorry Bro.
It seems like that.
Yeah,
I was just saying that what I always loved and hated about black crowds was
they're going to have fun either way.
The they having fun with it.
Yeah.
Cause you're killing or you're going to,
they're going to laugh at you.
Either way you kill.
Oh yeah,
there'll be either you tell the joke and people laugh or you tell the joke.
There's a pause.
Somebody else says something and then there's like the big laugh dude.
I remember one time fucking eaten it in front of all black crowd and uh,
there's this comedy club called mix and nuts and now it's called the comedy
union out here in California.
So,
uh,
out here in La and I'm doing,
I go up to that dude and just from the,
from the get go,
I am just bombing.
30 seconds in,
I got dry mouth and I am just,
and then I'm just plowing through my act and nobody is saying anything.
There's not a sound in the room.
It's just the sound of my dry lips as I'm fucking doing these jokes.
And finally,
two and a half excruciating minutes of dead silence.
This big girl in the back just just calm his shit,
just looks at a friend and just goes,
I laughed yet.
And the whole place just goes through everybody.
And then they just started laughing at me and I didn't know how to address it
and I stayed in my act and just,
he didn't the bubble.
Like I was doing my show at some other comedy club where people were listening
to it and it was fucking the,
I'm getting embarrassed out dates for the fucking humiliation of that to stay in
your act as the worst part about it too.
It's like they're just trying to hide behind this bubble.
That of words that don't exist man,
you know?
No,
you have to,
you,
you have to address it.
Like it's weird like,
oh,
white crowd will almost get uncomfortable with you.
But either way you have to break the tension.
But I'm getting back to the,
the Boston comedy club.
Dude,
I had such horrific set say when I first started,
you don't,
when you first came to town,
like Steinberg and frost would fucking test you when they put you on.
I have to read Johnny in the round guy who murdered.
They were this comedy team and I remember they would end this set doing,
uh,
their version of that song.
It takes,
it takes two,
it takes two to make a thing go right.
Insane.
And it would be flicking the fucking lights on and off,
on and off a dude.
You literally felt like,
dude,
I have,
I don't have a joke in my act.
And they would just throw you.
All that stuff shows over after that,
the show is over.
Everybody go home after you.
Like I ever saw a new guy I ever saw it go down and fucking not only killed but
fucking level after it was Dane Cook,
Dane Cook,
I believe that the energy,
oh yeah,
dude,
he went up there and that's the funny thing about all the fucking shit that was
said about that guy.
Like they don't understand like the level that that guy murdered.
I'll never understand that.
Right dude?
He went up to and just fucking like,
he,
he treated them like that.
He was like,
they weren't like as guys opener.
He just took it to an entirely different level.
And,
um,
I remember Steinberg years later was talking about him and Jason ran the room
back then and he said to me,
he just said,
yeah man.
He goes,
I couldn't bury the kid,
I couldn't bury him.
And,
and I remember thinking like,
yeah,
I knew you guys used to do that.
You used it when guys came down,
it was the exact opposite of any other club where they'd be like,
oh,
he's a new guy.
Put it up early,
put them up after the fucking,
you know,
okay,
act when you went to the Boston Comedy Club Day and meet,
they threw you right into the fire and they write into the deep end.
And I think that that's why I wanted,
I kept going back there.
Do I use least?
We still walk by that club and during the day,
if I saw it,
I got sick to my stomach just going like,
oh God,
that fucking like it dude.
It literally had my heart sometimes I didn't even recognize it during the day.
I'd be halfway past and go,
Oh shit,
there it is.
Just because it's such a night thing,
a dark light,
yeah.
Thing.
And,
but the thing about it too is,
uh,
you know,
the idea that you had to go through there and do that.
I like sometimes it'll be on the road now and like these features go,
I'm deciding if I should move to la or New York and Da da Da.
And they talking about comedy and like the one question,
like you got to ask yourself as,
do you love it?
You got to love it so much that like we were blind to that man.
It was no big deal.
You walk home after getting beaten and batted there and yeah,
and you always kills me is quitting.
Never even like,
I never even thought about quitting.
I would just immediately be thinking about,
I felt was getting past,
I've tried to think of like,
uh,
like how I could do better the next time.
I just remember the worst part was just when you went to bed and just you just
laying in your fucking,
I had,
oh,
I had a walkthrough bedroom,
railroad apartment back then.
Remember that shit up on 97th street,
right?
Yeah.
And I would fucking just be laying there in the bed just like with the
humiliation of the set,
just going through my fucking head and everything and like,
like it would take you all the way until like maybe two in the afternoon the
next day to finally get your feet for me anyways,
get my feet back underneath me and then I have a spot at the strip and he'd go,
Oh yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Thank God.
I'm still funny.
I,
I'm still funny,
but like I think that there was a lot of guys that went down to the Boston
comedy club and got their heads handed to them and then they went back up to
those uptown clubs,
uh,
meaning like the standup New York and the Strip and they just stayed there.
And I think that that hurt him as comedians because I mean,
who's kidding,
who doing the Boston comedy club exclusively would also hurt you because then
you become a hell Rome comic.
You needed that balance of both where you go to the comic strip,
you like,
oh,
this,
this feels like let's what must be what it's like when you make it.
That's cardio when working out like the comic strips cardio than comedy clubs,
squats deadweights
what do they call those things?
Kettlebells.
Yeah.
All that nasty stuff,
man.
Exactly.
I was the biggest difference.
And you'd go uptown sometimes and then you'd be like,
oh,
this is,
this is easy peasy.
I mean,
every,
this is so easy.
But then you'll start to look,
sometimes when I go uptown late to the strip,
I'd sit in the back and I'd be like,
I think it's the same white guy,
just changing outfits.
Like,
uh Oh,
they had that.
They had that song.
Yeah.
Rest his soul.
You,
I'm first time it came down to the comic strip and I Ellucian whole legend in
the,
uh,
New York comedy scene in stand up in general.
And I remember calling there and just being like,
hey,
Lucia just wanted to do as myself.
And he's built Burma,
comedian from Boston and he just nods his head and he just went,
I already have enough white guys.
And there was so many white guys that got offended by that.
Go do digital fucked up.
If you said that about a black guy,
little bit like lacking,
like it was the same thing.
It's just like,
dude,
I know what this guy's saying.
Yeah,
don't be another guy coming in here talking about the same shit.
I just took that immediately.
It's like if you don't have a unique voice,
I'm not going to get you on stage cause I already have enough of you.
Well that's exactly it because I would go down anywhere,
even at a comedy cell for example,
and I would have like my clever joke about something that happened in the news
and then I'd be like,
well I'm wasting my time because Geraldo in a tell doing this shit way better
than I have a crime and they're way more invested in it.
So I'm just going to talk about my life,
you know?
And then,
and then I took one lesson where I was going to lose my accent.
I had the damn car wine cork in my mouth to try to,
you know,
I'm like,
wait,
what the fuck am I doing?
Just be who you are.
It's all this shit that's separating you from every other white guy.
Sometimes you don't have a lot y'all festival.
I'm sorry man.
Every guy in Canada is like,
I mean,
uh,
who's the one who does this?
I love that he does that.
It's the only,
it's the most physical thing I've ever seen.
A comedian comic duo.
The WHO's the one who,
oh,
no,
uh,
oh my God.
Love them fucking murders.
Yeah.
He's so funny man.
Uh,
Jeremy is something anyway,
yeah,
Jay,
I,
he touches his nose.
That's like the most physical thing.
I was that guy when you got a guy's got to go see we do,
when that guy gets on a fucking roll,
he almost kills people when he keeps going up.
Piece of shit that is
do once the crowd buys in.
Like,
uh,
I,
I that's one of the hardest comics I've ever had to follow a hymn.
Greer Barnes.
Oh forget it.
Yeah.
Would I even want to go back to the city now when I play,
I always look ahead to see if Grissom before me cause that's the one we were
like,
all right to the love of crowd has for Greer Barnes.
If he's doing eight minutes,
forget about if he's doing like a 15 minute spot.
Like I always felt like when I went on stage after him,
I literally felt the disappointment.
Like they were like,
oh,
you know,
another black comic,
another guy going to do all this cool beat box and characters and all this crazy
shit.
And I was just going to come up.
They'd be like,
Hey,
you know what's up with Bill Clinton?
Like no one got,
no one gave a fuck.
You literally felt like the,
the uh,
I,
and he's won a few guys.
I ever just felt like just,
just disappointment was it was,
and I always thought it was so genuine to where it's like obviously if you go on
after like some uh,
you know,
some soap star or some shit like that,
that's a different thing.
He was just like that guy from day one and he's another guy.
Man,
I can't figure out why that guy doesn't,
well he's got that bit too.
For example,
where we scuba dive in and he's on the water and the majority of the pit is
complete silence.
He doesn't say anything for like three minutes and he's making the noises of the
bubbles and he's acting this shit out in his fucking murderer.
No,
I'm old school.
I think you're a little like this too.
When there's no laugh tickle.
I get all bugged out.
I'm like,
it's cold.
I mean,
how would I come in it and like when I saw you do,
like I said the,
well we were having a catch that made me,
you know,
again,
it's brewed,
does that too.
Chapelle take your time.
Don't worry.
If there's no laughter,
they're going to come in big at the end.
But you know,
like,
like Chapelle sometimes we'll have these two minute bits where you're not
supposed to be laughing and then the end,
this is going to make you die laughing.
But I,
I'd be too worried in the two minutes.
I'm like,
oh,
it is better to have a big ending.
He was fucked up though,
is what I first started out.
I took a comedy class.
This guy Vinny favorito,
who's now in a,
he works in Vegas.
And uh,
I'll never forget,
he said something in that class.
He was talking about people like,
you know,
talking about silence and people being afraid of it.
And he was saying,
you know,
it's weird,
you swatch a comic up there and then fucking blah,
blah,
going like 90 miles an hour and it's not going well.
And he goes,
and all of a sudden they go and they tell a street joke and they'll just be
like,
all right,
two guys walk into a bar,
right?
There's a horse in one day.
And he goes immediately,
the crowds shuts the fuck up and they listen.
He goes the gun to listen.
It feels like a story.
So like usually like a street joke with somebody tells you a street joke,
you're going to sit there for 45 seconds waiting for the punchline.
Yeah,
true.
But you do.
If the guy tells the story the right way,
it's gonna happen.
So I remember,
um,
for whatever reason that stayed with me,
but it took me I think like 19 years to be able to apply that to be able to go
into areas where,
I just think New York and Boston comedy scenes are similar where it was like you
get on stage,
once you get your foot on their neck,
you don't take it off for the rest of the set and you like just beat the shit
out of him every fucking eight seconds.
Like that was what you were trying to do.
And there was,
even when I was in Boston,
I would say like Tony Vee and Kenny Rogers and we're the only guys that I,
that I saw that had more of like a relaxed style.
And could still murder and then you can come up there and come back and right.
I should dynamics it does.
But when you say,
and how it took you a long time to really apply it,
like,
oh my first special,
I have a bit long story short where at the end of it I say some about,
uh,
being a Cobra and a basket,
you know,
when someone plays the flute.
So I pretend I'm a cobra and the basket,
right?
And the bit is the flutes playing and I get excited and eventually I pop out.
And uh,
the thing about is I love it and it's funny,
but if I'm not doing it just right,
I'm scratched down and what?
I'm scratched down,
I can tell.
But you didn't have pop up.
Oh,
they're not going to laugh.
I'm going to be popping up like an asshole.
The complete silence.
I literally pop up and go into that as I'm popping up.
I go,
I flew the other day on southwest like I'm already into the next fit for.
I'm done doing the fucking slick.
Do you remember,
do you remember doing the danger fields?
Dude,
I was a danger fields the last time.
Rodney went on stage.
I was on the show.
He was on,
it was incredible.
Man.
Are you serious?
I came in,
it was a Saturday night.
I mean he was,
he died like about a month after that.
And a Tony who runs the place,
it was packed because it's bridge and tunnel Saturday night.
Mike Britt is how am seeing and he goes to the Brits,
a beast beast.
So funny,
so funny.
And uh,
Tony Goes,
listen,
Rodney's in the crowd.
A lot of people don't know what he's sitting with his wife right up front in his
robe and he's going to come on after you Pete.
And uh,
you know,
he liked it.
He didn't even really,
it was very old,
you know,
so it wasn't going to be much of anything.
So,
uh,
I'm going to do 15 minutes in front of Rodney.
The guys like going to die any day.
I try to do every joke I ever written in 15 minutes.
Like he might pop up,
shake my hand and go,
let me make it.
Few your phone calls for you.
The guy didn't even know he was in doors.
Billy and I'm rattling off all night.
Right.
So I get off,
I stand off to the side and uh,
my Britt introduces Rodney place goes crazy.
Okay.
Rodney gets up,
he's walking so slow,
it's like from here to the wall and it takes him like 20 minutes at 55 solid
minutes with his wife helping him.
The people even stop clapping.
So I started clapping.
So they keep the class.
I mean keep the clap.
He grabs them like an imperfect Rodney voice.
If you close your eyes,
it's not a,
he grabs the mic and about Mike Brady goes,
how about another round of applause for the Moon Yan?
Huh?
It my wrist.
I was cracking up to it and he puts his arm around Mike Brady does about a
minute and a half,
some joke.
It was very funny and worked and then he,
and then he shuffled off and then he passed away in about a month.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I didn't meet him or shake his hand or anything cause he was back in the
crowd and I had to get back down to the cellar.
Oh yeah.
What would they think about danger fields?
That when we came to New York,
that club was like,
it was in a bad place where it was just like they had comics that had been
working there since the fucking place had opened.
And it just,
I went in there one night,
dude.
And that was one of those nights where I felt like quitting comedy.
I watched this come back and say this comics name,
but I saw this guy on stage and it was the most bleakest,
darkest,
like the negativity that was hanging in the fucking air.
And then what happened was Jim Norton.
Yes,
you just said his name.
yes.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Like I watched three minutes that guys sent in.
If I,
if there was a gun in the room,
I would've had it in my mouth.
I would have shot him first just out of just humanity.
How fucking bleak this guy was.
So,
yeah,
that's the kind of guy you want to play in a movie to win your Roscoe and
independent film thought and what are you going home to?
What are you doing when you get home,
man?
Right.
He was sitting in there and like,
dude,
I'm not lying.
I love danger fields.
But the reverb on that,
Mike was fucked up for like seven years straight.
Nobody adjusted it.
You what was the worst is you do like a higher energy bit and there was nobody
in there that fucking Echo,
you know,
which sounds great on like a dean Martin album,
like fills out his voice.
But if you fucking doing like singing,
I mean I'm doing jokes,
it w e your balls,
but Norton was the guy that first started doing it.
Yes,
you guys got to go there.
You get to do a half hour,
$45.
Norton single handedly,
I think saved that place because he got us all to go there.
I remember everybody was giving him shit.
I remember Patrice rest,
his soul goes,
uh,
he goes,
wait,
coming from Norton,
he goes Dangerfield.
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
hey,
he goes,
who did you go on after Ruth buzzy
and everybody's dying laughing.
And Norton defended it though.
He was going,
dude,
you got to go up there.
So I was living on the upper east side like you and you and I started doing it
and then I remember Shirad came in and then there was his great thing.
It just all of a sudden just fucking turned around.
Yeah.
Those older guys took off and left and uh,
but what was weird was that,
you know,
and is cool as the decor remained the exact same.
Like if you're into like shit from back in the day,
you got to go to danger fields.
It really looks like,
you think,
you feel like Johnny Carson is going to come walking in when he still had like
jet black hair or brown hair and shit.
Like when,
when you sit in there with those,
those little fucking,
it was a little lamp shades.
Yeah.
Everybody writes their initials on the lampshades and uh,
it's literally like a lounge in Vegas from 1970.
They only have male waiters and the weight is all still wet or red jackets,
career weight or it's,
yeah,
and it's,
it's just,
uh,
you know,
I mean the photos on the wall when you first come in because like Billy Joel did
a song for easy,
easy money for Rodney's movies.
So there's a photo of Billy Joel was there and you know,
Sinatra and all these great Elvis,
Elvis with Rodney.
But then the thing would happen after a while bill is I would play there and uh,
then I'd be back at the seller and you know,
sometimes in between spots,
everyone sits around and chats and I'm running out and no one's like,
wait,
are you going?
I'm like,
God,
I got gotta Dangerfield.
And he's like,
oh,
you still got an a day and you feel like it stopped.
And I,
because he got to the point where it's 75 bucks.
I live around the corner and I'd be like,
how can I not bop in and just get a quick 75 title few mummy's?
I fucking love that place.
Sometimes.
Other times it would just literally,
it's the only place I had a breakdown where I was like the,
Oh,
the only time where I was ever looking at the crowd.
Like,
what did you just call me if the fucking heat,
why are you even here?
Dude,
I saw.
So I've seen some of the,
one of the fucking most bizarre heckles I ever got and one of the best tackles I
ever saw I saw in that room.
All right.
The one that happened to me,
right,
I'm fucking standing on stage and this,
this,
this group,
I told this one time,
I think on a special ordinance was an extra something.
It was like four white dudes in the corner,
Dude.
And you could feel the fuck and anger coming off these guys.
You could feel the fucking awful dads that beat him with belt buckles and shit.
I'm,
I've never felt an energy like that.
So I go on stage and they're so fucking angry and there were a little loud being
drunk that they're intimidating the entire crowd.
So I'm standing on stage bombing and I know I'm bombing because those fucking
guys,
their energy and everything in me is saying,
don't say anything.
Don't say anything,
just fucking get through the shit.
And then finally I was just bombing so bad.
I had to say something.
I was just saying like,
what are you guys talking about over there?
They like what?
I said,
yeah wait,
what are you guys talking about over there?
And the guy yells out,
he goes,
anything read non stages.
A faggot.
That's what he said,
which I don't even know what the fuck that means.
Like it was just so fucking like childish and I just,
but,
but then it was hilarious and I'm sitting there going like,
I went right back into my act and I was sitting there.
Pardon me,
is law.
I'm furious.
The other part of me is laughing my ass off because I can't wait to go down the
cellar and luckily tell the story through.
That's like saying anybody who's sitting over there,
his girl germs or cooties,
like something in the second grade.
But it was still fucking hilarious.
And just eating my pulse and they did nothing about it off again whatsoever.
And I just sat there eating my balls and got offstage and I had to walk by the
fucking table.
It just,
I don't know that they had that one and then there was the guy.
Uh,
but it makes you better man.
Somehow those make you better,
man.
It makes you low my mind that in a hotel room.
But there was always that thing where we'd like when if they,
if you're actually in a comedy club and they're not policing it at all,
you're just like,
oh,
you give a fuck is that these people are eating and drinking and if they yell at
me or throw shit at me,
you don't give a fuck as long as they pay the check in the end.
But,
um,
the other time,
uh,
I don't know how to do this show because I don't want to say the guy's name
because I'm saying the name,
but I'd tell the danger fields,
jokers story.
But go ahead and write to this actor.
Slash comedian goes on stage.
All right.
People can figure out what is,
what am I going to say?
His name out of respect.
So he fuck,
and he's one of the funniest comics.
I know.
I'm going to say it.
Frank Santa.
Really?
It's one of the funniest guys ever go with a cigarette and he does a cigarette.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Fucking hilarious.
One of my favorites of all time.
So He's on stage and uh,
it's just this fucking one of those summertime crowds,
whether it just fucking sit in there and when those things like why the fuck did
you people come out here.
Exactly.
So this sitting there and he goes up on stage and he's on the soprano's going to
place the bartender thing.
So he goes on stage and they're just not having it.
They're not listening,
they're not laughing.
And his shit is really,
it's like Greer Barnes where like he'll go into a bit and it's like this 10
minute high level concept thing and then not buying it.
So finally,
you know,
he's like 10 years older than me,
so he's trying to reach out to this crowd because it's a young crowd.
He goes,
hey man.
uh,
you,
you guys liked the soprano's.
How'd you guys like the Sopranos?
He goes,
I played so-and-so.
Ah,
I played the bartender every week.
Uh,
Tony Soprano beats the shit out of me and this guy in the back without missing a
beat goes,
you should have killed you.
I don't even know to this day of frank ever heard it.
I was like,
oh my God,
that's fucking hilarious.
So,
and I wanted to laugh my balls off,
but I had to go on next to,
so I'm literally watching the beat down that I'm going to take.
Right.
It was like when your mother would line you all up and you know,
to beat you or whatever,
and you're like waiting like,
okay,
this,
this.
Maybe she'll get tired by the time she gets to me.
Right.
She'll get a phone call,
something.
Yeah.
So he walked off stage.
I remember he walked by me.
It's still classic.
Frank.
Funny as hell.
Didn't say anything.
He just walks by me.
Just doesn't look at me.
Just goes,
wow.
Wow.
He said it twice.
That's all he could do at that place.
Sometimes.
I mean,
Carrie Carrabba's used to be on stage there at night.
We're doing prom shows.
I used to do prom shows that,
oh no,
I just,
I mean that's literally just go,
if you can just go up there and stay up there for 10 minutes,
you get your 50 bucks or whatever it was.
It was,
it was not about comedy.
It wasn't about anything.
Or You'd have a better chance going to port authority and just with a Mr
microphone,
you'd get more laughs.
She would yell from the stage.
Cause I'd be last,
she'd be second the last sheet yell from the stage,
call reality.
I got five,
four minutes,
five more minutes.
How fucking jealous I yeah.
Ah Man.
That she's bragging that she doesn't have to be in front of them in the moment.
It's completely then get it and the club and the club would latch on to the
weirdest characters to be there.
Like comic,
like the comic of,
you know,
how like,
certain comics,
like it tells known for the comedy cellar,
right?
The 12 o'clock spot.
Yeah.
So,
like I remember danger fields went through a phase with Steve Marshall was
hosting all the shows and he was that guy and he's not there to behave.
Oh yeah,
have,
I'm not here to behave.
That's right slogan.
So he would do,
it is so weird.
He would do his last bit every show,
he'd have a dozen roses and he would slam each rose against the piano as he had
a comment about women like,
and then you blah blah blah.
Uh,
and then at the end,
you know,
the show would end and then when everyone left he'd have to go back in and pick
up his roses.
It's like the club wouldn't even do four.
And then,
and then like I remember in between shows sometimes,
cause there was a Korean Deli word get the roses,
you know,
they're like,
Steve,
you're next.
So until I was running late and he goes,
I don't even have my roses yet.
And even go get them up and they go,
well hurry.
Have to go get your roses.
So He'd have to run to the Korean Deli,
get his fucking roof.
Not to mention that's half your paycheck and flowers men,
right?
Yeah Dude.
And we've going with that dude.
That's what,
it doesn't have any charge suit.
I remember I used to work in a dental office.
I worked in a dental office with my dad when I started out.
And we used to have like when we were really drilling into somebody's tooth,
it was gross man.
Shit,
we'd be flying out of the mouth.
So you basically had this plastic,
it looked like a welder's mask but it was all plastic.
Yeah.
So all the spittle that would hit your face is hitting at the end.
I'll show it's fucking disgusting jump.
So,
um,
I got the idea one night that I was going to put it on cause I was so young I
was going to put it on on stage or whatever and I was going to,
this is going to be my closing pit.
So for like,
like maybe two and a half months in my standup career,
I had this little duffle bag and I would be bringing the stupid mask on stage.
And the funniest thing was,
I didn't even have a joke.
I would just put it on,
I would just say like,
you know,
my job during day,
you don't,
it's like working there.
Who job stinks so bad,
I got to wear this.
And I would put on and they'd sort of chuckle and they were like,
and,
and where does this go?
And I would just have the thing on and with the screen in front of me,
like muffling my voice,
I'd be like,
who are you guys as I'm taking it off.
And finally one day I figured it out.
I was,
I was talking to this comic,
got Todd Parker and a god,
we come a long way.
Holy Shit Dude.
And I said to him,
Oh yeah,
I actually thought that that was funny.
So I talked to him,
I said,
you know,
I'm not going to do that match thing in the morning.
I remember he was sitting at the cow loom,
this arms crossed looking forward,
not looking at me like I,
you know,
I'm not gonna do that mastering anymore.
And I was just like,
and he just goes,
oh yeah,
he's just looking at the stage.
I go,
yeah,
I just feel like I'm just saying like,
I'm so not funny.
I literally need to bring shit on stage to make myself funny.
And he just sort of looked at me goes,
yeah,
he figured that out.
And I remember my heart sinking going like,
oh my God,
every comic was thinking that and I didn't even know the whole,
he's a prop comic and all that shit that you know,
those guys go through,
which I don't give a fuck if you use props.
It's funny,
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
no,
that's a different thing.
But I mean if you're a prop guy,
your prop guy,
if you just got roses,
I mean that's it.
It's like I the that you got to go all in.
I got either got a bunch of props,
that's it or absolutely nothing.
I Vinnie favarino would've shut down.
The mask is,
yeah,
he definitely would have.
I got the,
actually I've got finally got the website for Pete's special streaming on
showtime.
Go to sho.com and click on comedy and it's going to be on there.
But uh oh yeah,
tell me.
But I could sit there and literally tell,
uh,
we haven't gotten to the New York comedy club all my swept day.
You know,
we're going to discourage people from becoming standups cause this is just gonna
cause the hell gigs of the funniest ones.
Well this is all though before the social media was what it was,
where like now instead of like I mopped and swept for stage time at the New York
comedy club.
Now you know,
you get yourself a nice little five minutes,
you get it on the right website is something,
I mean you get it out there and the on the Internet and then you could start to
feature.
That's the other thing too with features.
Now it's like Eh,
I mean you probably bring your own guys,
but when I'm on the road and these features are on the road,
it's like this,
it's like the MCS really into comedy.
The features like had it and his last bit always as t shirts sale.
And he's like,
do you mind if I sell?
And if I say,
well,
I'd rather you didn't stand next to me itself.
It's not a flea market.
You know what I mean?
Then he won't talk to me the whole weekend.
That's what happened the last time.
They guy won't talk to me.
Uh,
and,
and he's like,
you know,
they don't pay me enough to feature.
And it's like nobody gave a shit about me when I get paid enough money to
feature was
exactly when I featured,
I had a day job.
I mean Bruce would tell me how filled tag men that Phil tag that.
Yeah,
he had a quill,
he traveled with a coffee machine in his car and a waffle brew who told me about
what time.
He's like,
I worked with Phil,
but it's like brew,
we'll lived out of his car when he started.
Uh,
I worked front desk at a hotel forever.
I remember I worked for,
I don't want to be the guy who was all bitter on the new cause there's a bunch
of guys,
there's a lot of great guys.
Right.
But it's just the different thing is funny is I remember,
don't remember,
you don't have to do a lot of that anymore.
I remember being in working in Baltimore and I was working with the a feature
act and he was upset that he didn't get a half hour special and I just remember
thinking like,
dude,
when I want,
I started just,
this was like 10 12 years ago,
so I was only like 10 years.
And I'm thinking too,
when I started like the half hour specials they gave to like seasoned headliners
and they picked from an hour of,
you know,
I'm not saying there wasn't some week specials,
but like you had to be a headline and you had to pick from an hour.
It's shit.
It's like you're a feature,
right?
It's like we're going to go do your whole fucking act.
You can do everything together.
It's like they're almost doing you a favor and they don't see it that way.
But yeah.
Thank God.
Thank God through the fight.
Did any specials?
My Shit in the fucking 90 oh yeah,
dude,
I got the VHS tapes.
I remember I found them one time and I was watching it with my wife too.
I sat there,
I had my hand over my mouth.
I couldn't fuck.
I knew I was bad dude.
I couldn't believe how fucking bad I was,
how fast I was going.
Dude,
forget about the clothes and the big fucking red Afro.
Forget about all of that shit,
dude.
I was fucking horrible.
And uh,
that's the one thing that amazes me is these kids,
like they,
they get the from day one,
they're putting this shit up on the Internet,
but they all,
a lot of them are better than I was that quick.
I'll give him that.
Like,
you know,
some of these guys are young,
they're funnier than I was.
They figured out how to write jokes better than I did that young do the crown
node,
the crowd at this point,
they're making videos of each other and then they post them and they can buy
comments that they learn what plays and what doesn't.
Like,
I really think it's,
it's helped stand up because I think crowds in general are so much more educated
to uh,
to stand up comedy that it kind of pushes you to,
to,
you got to stay above,
you've got to keep your head above the water lines.
Yeah.
Or you're going to go under.
But there's obviously a bunch of great comics out there,
but like I think as much all we all,
we,
you're like,
I don't want to say stuff about the young comics,
so I'm like,
all right,
we're going to say good stuff about him now.
And then now you're playing what?
I will say whatever you want to say that,
but
I'm not that sweat that the New York comedy club to get stage time.
I mean shit,
the stuff we went through to get on,
uh Oh wait,
that wasn't what I wanted to tell you.
But here's the thing though,
this same technology that affords them to not have to have a day job is also
what's,
you know,
guys like us now decide when we're going to do a special.
So it's helping everybody.
But I do know what you mean.
You almost like a,
not even like an asshole way,
like,
well I had to do this so you should have to do this.
I think it helps you.
No,
no,
that's it.
It just makes you better.
I mean,
you know,
I see guys now sometimes that become a famous early and then you can see them
when you're on a show with them or something.
They bite and the finger nails man.
And they were a little worried because they don't have like,
like I'll give you an example.
One time I opened for our old friend,
you must know Billy Gardell,
right?
Oh yeah.
From Mike and Molly.
He's so funny man.
And I've done towards that and he's just such a,
he's really funny comedian and uh,
it's in,
we're playing in Niagara Falls at the falls view casino.
I was getting more money than I've kind of ever got to open for him.
I can't imagine when he was getting,
and it's all these high role is in the crowd and stuff and he goes up and he's
doing,
I said to my wife was,
here I go,
this is going to be so funny because like when you pay this much money to see
somebody,
you almost don't expect them to be good.
Yeah.
Cause they don't know anything about them.
You're almost paying just to see the guy.
Right.
And for the first five minutes you could see the look in their eyes like Whoa,
wait,
wait.
He's got jokes.
I might tell he's just going to come up here and talk about,
uh,
you know,
and it's like being on the show and that's from years and years of doing clubs
and paying dues to get to that point.
Man,
I think you just,
you,
you got,
you know,
you could see the relaxation in them.
It's not like,
oh no worry at all.
Like,
yeah,
we're going to have fun.
Yeah.
He's effortless storyteller.
He's just,
one of those guys would be like,
know I was in Chicago two weeks ago and you're in the way.
I am.
What happened?
Well,
so then when I used to work front desk,
I've got to tell you,
this is funny,
I worked front desk of,
sorry,
you've got a roll.
No,
no,
no.
It's hilarious.
I mean there's no way to look at the clock without the guests.
Think of that.
I just going to make sure I don't go over.
Oh,
all right.
Well yeah,
let me,
we got another guy coming in here like 12 or whatever.
All right.
I got another guy coming in and looking at the car.
So you know I'm doing well,
I'm doing the old salesman thing.
The Guy Coming in here at 12 so Sebastian was telling me that you flying
helicopters.
Yeah,
I don't want to hear it dude.
I don't want to hear it.
If you're going to shoot it,
like only one thing I learned this to shit on.
Okay.
I'm just going to say it's not like the hardest thing to fly,
right?
Uh,
no,
this shit way harder than that.
But I mean it's more difficult than I guess fixed wing.
I've never taught this as a regular sets the thing,
but it's,
it's no,
it's the hardest shit is the ground school.
All the shit that comics hate,
have an add learning all the,
uh,
all of that shit.
Looking at charts,
the airspace,
whether all of that stuff.
Um,
it's the biggest accomplishment of my more so than even becoming a comedian,
just as far as how I'm wired,
how difficult I thought it was gonna be.
I just just kept going there and it was fun.
And,
um,
but I've learned with anything,
whenever you do something like move to la or fly in helicopters,
like there's just like a certain,
or just put your shit out on the Internet,
there's always that new level of tough skin.
You're going to have to get,
like,
you go to la every was like,
oh my God,
there's so plastic.
Everybody's so phony.
You lose your edge,
the comic stink and you're going to have botox in your face and you've got to
like block all of that out.
Right.
And then like with aviation I've learned is just if the person you talked to
also doesn't fly,
they're just going to tell you you're going to die immediately.
Just got to like go.
You just got to block it out.
I flew yesterday,
dude,
the first time I flew in like a little over a month and I can't even tell you
how much fucking fun it was.
I flew from Long Beach,
I went up to seven,
10 north and I went straight up.
It goes right to pass the dean and right the left.
You see the Rose Bowl.
I'll show you a video.
I did a loop around the rose bowl.
Are you,
are you solo at this point?
No,
I'm doing it solo.
Uh,
tomorrow.
Like I just like,
I'm,
I'm really cautious because I was going like,
all right,
let me do this flight once with the instructor and I go and then I'll come back
Thursday,
I'll do it once with you and then I'll do it.
And by the time I was coming flying back,
I was like,
dude,
I can do this one by myself.
And he goes,
Hey,
he goes,
you're totally ready.
You got your head on a swivel,
you're doing the radio calls,
you've got the whole,
he got it down.
So,
uh,
but why copter overplaying?
Why Not Plain?
I mean copters so like,
yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
I drive a jeep wrangler,
jeep wrangler right there.
That's like a cop.
The,
yeah.
You didn't fucking grow up watching a magnum Pi.
We didn't [inaudible] I wanted to be the guy in the helicopter.
That was awesome.
Hey Man,
what are you kidding me?
Yeah.
Low TC Rick and a magnum dude.
I love that.
You think of jeep is cool.
That's so our generation,
like,
I don't know if kids think I fucking,
yeah,
I have such a great Boston storage.
Reminds me,
you will Roberts sometimes with the accent.
My brother lived in Boston for a little while and um,
my wife and I,
Jackie were visiting him.
I had a my jeep wrangler.
It Has New York plates and even says Manhattan on it.
Cause it was a Manhattan dealership.
Had we won the world series yet?
Uh,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
that's,
that's not too bad.
No,
it's not too long ago.
And I'm at a red light and a,
nobody's banging a right to turn.
Right.
And I'm just saying to my wife and summertime,
right at the top down,
I'm like typical fucking Boston.
I mean,
just bang the rate.
What are you doing here?
Right,
right,
right next to me as a parking lot.
So I'm like,
Hey,
screw these people.
I'm just going to my head.
I'm like,
I'm just going to cut through the parking lot.
So I just turned the wheel and I'm going to cut through the parking lot.
Now what I didn't see is there was a curb right next to me,
so I floor it and I turned the wheel and the jeep hits the curb and like the dog
almost flies out of the jeep.
My wife had bangs,
everything.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
You know,
and we're just trying to regroup and imperfect Boston accent right behind me.
Here's some guy yell out ea,
you go New York,
you hear well you go,
oh,
I just like,
oh my God,
I'll fucking embarrass the you write out.
And he just keeps yelling.
I mean here,
I don't wait for the lie.
Oh God,
I know.
Hey,
I gotta ask you as far as,
uh,
as far as,
your,
you're a sports affiliation is,
I remember you're one of those weird jets,
Yankees guys.
Cause it's always jets,
mets,
Yankees,
giants.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that's it.
Yeah.
I took a year off with the Yankees hat.
I'm in mourning.
Fajita I just took a whole season red sox fan duel on hateable,
one of the,
one of the few on a hateable people like Steph curry on hateable.
Yeah.
Can't hate him.
What's like big Papi man?
It's even like Tom Brady.
I mean I'm a jet fan,
but it's like I've saying,
last year we were doing a show and someone was talking about a Russell Wilson
Zeus and that I go,
listen,
Russell Wilson's great for Seattle Come Brady is great for America.
Yeah,
we lost,
obviously I was actually in my last podcast.
I did,
I was watching the game live and are loving it and like hear me flipping out and
everything.
But I gotta be honest with you,
dude,
after watching that year,
we went 18 in one like dude and undefeated record in this day and age,
it's not like when the fucking Dolphin stadium,
you know what I mean?
When you had like white cornerbacks and shit and it was still,
you know,
sports was five minutes after the end of the dude drop 30 on Bob Cousy if he was
playing today.
All right,
it's a different time.
I'm not going to find out about them.
To me,
that's Hilarious,
dude.
That's fucking hilarious.
But they like an undefeated record is a fucking albatross around your goddamn
neck.
People get people already get amped up.
If you're defending super bowl champions or if you had a nice run,
they want to fucking beat you,
then they just want to be the guy that knocked you off.
I remember that year we went 18 and one like,
dude,
what we we fucked up was because Raymond Genie,
uh,
drop dime on us that we were filming fucking the signs and Shit.
And then everybody questioned all of our titles.
So then they went into this rape and pillage mode for about three weeks and they
were like,
oh yeah,
this is what we could have been doing to you.
And they would,
that's only started doing that shit.
Like,
you know,
going for two and running up in the score and they weren't embarrassing people.
It was the dumbest thing we could ever do by October.
Everyone was like,
you're not fucking embarrassing us until we played like a playoff level
atmosphere.
I swear to go somewhere around the cowboy game of the cult game in mid October
for the rest of the,
if I'm over the ravens that year with somebody sucked and we played a Monday
night football and the place was packed and people were like,
what the towel at the terrible towel thing going over they head for a fucking
like a game and no fat.
Yeah.
And they,
and they were completely out of the point.
Maybe it wasn't the ravens window completely out of the playoff picture.
So I'm actually,
um,
I don't give a fuck about the undefeated thing.
You want the championship.
But of course.
So what I'm nervous about is like the only star we got left is Brady.
Everybody's,
everybody's out.
Yeah.
But come on,
let's be honest.
I mean,
you got my next door neighbor.
Your next door neighbor could be running cross patterns for Brady next week for
all we know.
I mean,
did I,
did anyone know Adelman?
Uh,
these little white guys just drive,
I don't even know any of these guys except for the graph.
I felt the same way about Magic Johnson.
Like if I ever played on the Lakers,
he at my age right now,
47 year old,
slow fucking white dude.
If I played with magic on the showtime Lakers at the end of the game,
somehow I would have like three points.
I should have had like 12th.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
he'll set you up a,
how did it happen?
I don't know.
He was,
yeah.
And the other way everybody went to,
and then I had it and I have 3.5 other times you'd be going back down and go,
my bad,
my bad magic.
Yeah.
Like this.
There's a few guys out there that I liked that.
So I got to ask as a jets fan.
Um,
hi.
How did you feel about the move with Rex Ryan?
Uh,
getting rid of him,
but did you feel like he ran the course or whatever?
Cause I think that guy's a really,
he's a really good coach.
He just,
I feel like his big thing is he hasn't had a quarterback.
Like,
yeah,
I'm Sanchez was not as good as people said he was,
but he's not as bad as they say.
Like I think,
you know,
I think he should be starting up a Bradford,
well,
I don't know man.
I mean he's,
he's got no,
it's soft.
This throws a soft.
It has,
there's no canon,
isn't it?
I mean,
now we've got Fitzpatrick who is too short.
I've never seen a guy's balls get knocked down so many times.
It drives me nuts.
But you're right.
I mean,
but why can rex Ryan just come out and say,
yeah,
is that so bad to say?
It's like,
give me a quarterback and I'll wait.
And Man,
I've never had even now of came into New England beat,
you guys beat us in the playoffs in New England after we fucking killed you in
December when it didn't fucking count.
You guys came back.
Um,
does,
that's the thing about him.
If we meet the bills again in the playoffs,
like that's in the back of my head.
I'm thinking like,
all right,
who do they got out there in Buffalo for quarterback a tie Rod Taylor.
I looked outside there.
Yeah.
You're like,
what?
Rochester?
No,
I live or I said about this small town called for Donya but 45 minutes away from
Buffalo Dude,
I lived where I went to college.
I lived down the block from my college.
Now how do you,
how do you like it out there?
I,
it's a small town,
college at town.
I love it.
But I mean,
so I know you've got to go back.
I'll tell you real quick.
No,
no.
I played basketball division three there.
Right,
right.
And by my junior year I was named captain and I quit.
And I remember the coach bringing me in and he's like,
you're making a big mistake.
But all the guys had played with already gone now as young kids and they didn't
like to drink and party on the road,
which I did.
So I was like,
I'm done with these guys.
Wait a minute.
You were going to be captain of the team was cat and you quit cause your
teammates wouldn't drink and smoke with you?
Well I didn't smoke,
but yeah,
because it's fucking awesome.
Yeah.
But they wouldn't like old school.
But I'm like with division three are not on scholarship.
That dream is gone.
We'll go into Rochester for a weekend tournament.
You're not going to go out to the bar and meet Rochester,
the girls.
What do you it's,
so I'm a guy.
What are you going to play into the tarking Sunday it's done division three I'll
send it was six four get the memo.
Yes.
So,
so my coach told me I regret it,
you know,
and I was like,
no,
I'm quitting.
And I do,
I do it.
I would literally have dreams as the years later that I was a senior dropping 40
points.
It was dumb.
I should,
I was in such a rush to party and I didn't realize the parties never over.
Especially when you graduated,
you moved to the city.
So cut to 22 what?
Two years later by chain of events.
My wife's from this area.
I have a daughter now.
She doesn't want to be in the city.
We moved back to,
and it's the nicest town around.
So we moved back and then living in a big old Victorian home right around the
corner from my college.
It's Christmas morning and I'm shoveling my driveway at 7:00 AM and a car pulls
up at the end of the driveway and I hear a voice go pee,
Cory,
Ellie.
And the window comes down and it's my coach.
I'm like coach.
And he goes,
I heard you move to town.
We're going to get coffee soon.
And then he looks out and he goes,
merry Christmas.
I ran into Jackie and I go,
Jackie,
it was to coach.
We're going to get coffee.
Oh
cause he,
he never really forgave me for that.
No,
he never forgave me is now there's just the school's a d or whatever,
you know,
and he's like,
oh,
we want you to come do a show for the,
for the kids and uh,
will you talk to the team?
I go,
I'll talk to the team about not quitting because they,
everyone quits.
They wanted to get a scholarship.
They didn't get a scholarship.
So then they go screw this and they quit and I'm going to tell them,
but was just funny man.
You know.
But I'm on the road a lot,
so it's not like,
no,
that's what,
no.
Believe me,
dude.
If I was in a,
uh,
if I was in a,
you know,
if I wasn't in this business,
I wouldn't live out here,
but I actually do love it out here.
I do too.
I like those here for a year.
My wife and I liked that I was getting into Boogie board and then Manhattan
beach,
you embrace it exactly what it is.
You know,
we're so east coast that,
you know,
eventually you're going back.
Like,
I don't know,
maybe I will.
Maybe I won't.
But it's just like so new winco like,
well,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
It depends what this drought to,
we might all have to go back,
but they,
uh,
the first time I lived in La in the late nineties,
I was like,
uh,
I hated it because I wanted to be in New York.
And then the next time when I came back out in like 2007 or eight when I came
out here,
I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to embrace it this time.
I'm going to fucking high.
He can,
I'm going to again,
go out to the beach.
I'm not going to the beach and to fucking pasty put like,
you know,
I got into the helicopter thing out here.
I played pickup hockey.
I've had,
I actually took the time to build the fucking life out here.
Sure.
Because the first time I was,
you know,
sitting in one bedroom apartments,
sparsely furnished,
I just was not,
I was not committed to the fuck that was back when they had all the pilot season
and all that.
That was a big fucking jerk off every year you'd come out here and try to get on
something.
But um,
but anyways,
to wrap it up here,
dude,
just no Christmas out here.
That's the only thing that pissed me off.
I mean I saw one treat,
I balled me the year I lived here,
unlike as is everybody Jewish,
there's like no nothing.
I mean we got the Carol's going back east man.
No Man.
Well look,
you can now you can skate,
you can go skating.
I don't know how they do this.
Especially with the fucking drought.
Like right outside the staples center.
You can somehow go skating and out in Santa Monica they have something like
every year.
But uh,
if you know where to go,
there's a place in Pasadena like this dude,
it's like the sickest fucking houses you've ever seen where they actually have
like,
oh,
they really get into it too.
It looks like Vanderbilt Rockafella type money and they have these all these
giant fucking trees that look like giant,
giant Christmas trees and uh,
I,
they're all fucking rich so they just pay somebody to come in with like a crane
and they light up all of these so called Christmas tree row or something to,
it's fucking insane.
It's like Illuminati money and they allow you to go down this street once a
year.
Yeah.
And then you got to fucking beat it.
But the four we get out of here,
dude,
you one of my favorites of all time.
You want to look great storytellers as people could sell a tell.
And this is a guy like don't sleep on peak.
Corey.
Ellie's new special,
let me tell you,
it's streaming right now on show.com s h o.com.
Just click on comedy is a,
he does an awesome podcast with Sebastian who was one of the best comics out
there.
Uh,
who actually he must told you he lived right down the hall from me when I lived
in that Shitty fucking one bedroom apartment they have no man through before.
I have a fucking,
before he ever did comedy,
I ran into him.
He's just a Chicago guy and he goes,
hey.
He's like,
you know,
you know Sebastian when he doesn't know.
Yeah.
He comes out and he goes,
hey,
your ra,
your comedian,
right?
Yeah.
And I go,
yeah,
you know,
I go on,
I'm all excited.
So we record
and he just kind of nods me into shutting up.
Like he sort of nodded and then I just sort of got quiet again.
He goes,
yeah,
I seen that senior.
Uh,
yeah.
I've been thinking,
I'm thinking about doing it,
you know,
how do you,
uh,
how do you go about that?
And so I gave him some advice and I kind of got to know him a little bit and
then I moved away like right after that.
And like four or five years later,
I'm coming out here,
same type of jerk off thing coming out here for a half hour special.
I got to pay my own way out here.
I show up,
I go on first at the comedy store,
there's five people in the fucking crowd.
I eat my balls.
I'm addressing how there's only five people there and nobody's laughing.
And then the guy was set up,
the fucking showcase gave me shit because it was nobody there.
He goes by two inch waist is so many times because we know there's nobody here.
We'll listen it to the material.
I always wanted to go back in time and be like,
Hey,
fuck head,
don't have a fucking showcase with no people in the fucking crowd.
How about that?
How about I just paid all this fucking money and I,
oh,
I'm still mad about that.
Oh,
I hear you man.
So anyways,
yeah,
so I went out there like fucking 2000 like three or four and this was like the
late nineties when I saw him.
And I see this guy on stage and I'm like,
I recognize them,
but I can't figure out where to go.
What's this guy's name?
And he goes,
Sebastian,
it's like,
who do I know?
One Sebastian my whole fucking life.
And I'm looking,
going to go that said,
fucking guy.
He's doing standup.
And that guy,
he did the hardest thing ever.
He started ground zero in Los Angeles.
Yeah,
that's like unheard of.
It's practically impossible and became a monster fucking comic who has an
unbelievable work ethic and writes it in like an,
I don't know.
So anyways,
Pete does a show with them on riot cast is called the Pete and Sebastian show on
the right cast network,
which is www dot [inaudible] dot com uh,
your Twitter is my Cory,
l.
E c o r r e a.
L e.
Your website is www dot [inaudible] dot com I'm thrilled you one of my
favorites.
And if you've seen this guy,
go see him on the road,
go see his comedy specials.
Don't so great to run into him,
man.
I'm an La,
you're in Rochester.
It never happens anymore.
Oh,
buffalo area.
I got to tell you one quick last thing I was,
someone said to me,
he has stuff changed for you.
And two days ago my wife and I are raking my leaves in the front lawn and a dude
comes by and look really good.
They're nice job,
but I swear the guy looks at me and he's like,
you got to call it.
Oh God.
I go,
no,
I live here.
Oh No.
Oh.
He's like,
oh,
cause you do see it.
It looks so fantastic.
Special comes out guys asking me if I'll rate it.
God Damn leaves.
Leesville see that's why you got to watch a special.
Thank you man.
It's been so great.
Hang on.
What you dude fucking,
I,
I imagine the next time I'll see you [inaudible] will be at some sort of a
comedy festival and we gotta we gotta do it up the way we used to.
Either that or you come into town,
you're going to give you a ride and at copter,
Bro.
Oh,
if you want to,
I will.
I'll take my chances,
man.
Yeah.
Dude,
come on.
Yeah,
I'm not worried of that word.
What sucks is we have is documented to cause then,
and God forbid something fucking happens setting.
He wasn't worried her.
All right you guys,
that's a,
that's the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Monday.
Just port Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Thank you for listening.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Have a good weekend.
You can't.